you know what always makes me makes
makes my heart warm you know what always
you know what always makes my heart
warm you know what always makes my heart
warm those
worm you know what makes my heart
warm hey do you know
what we promise to enjoy whatever
happens
okay you ever have to poop so bad you
peace
second got softer during the lockdown I
knew I was in trouble you ever take the
top off a pint of ice cream and just
throw the lid
away got a CN growing up remember the CN
you pull the string it lands on the cat
100% real it goes this is the sound of a
cat
[Music]
meow Minnesota it's just the
guy it's you realize what this means
they couldn't get a
cat that is a story that is a man in a
room filled with scratching posts with a
boom mic and dozens of cats just like
come
on I believe in God
relax some people think God created the
universe some people think nothing
created the universe which is the
funniest
guess and the nothing people make fun of
the God people they say God doesn't
exist I'm like okay maybe
but you know what definitely doesn't
exist
nothing if you're offended by that joke
I completely
agree I offend myself every
day and so do you if you watch your
thoughts you ever come home from a party
drop your keys on the counter just like
I am not for everyone you know what I
mean
just it's nothing
new it's going to ensive the whole time